[Musique]
history of au nombre d'acteurs problèmes
de fatigue m'a séduit mathieu la routine
de 5,9 alors c'est le nom d'un logiciel
vendu par une société israélienne qui
s'appelle ls au groupe et ce logiciel
est vendu à des états des gouvernements
qui s'en servent en fait pour pour
espionner des personnels officiellement
et qu'asus ça c'est un logiciel qui
censée traquer les criminels les
terroristes mais c'est tout et pas les
journalistes pas les militants des
droits de l'homme pas les avocats les
chefs d'état est ce que l'on découvre
c'est un usage fait part du gouvernement
qui ont ciblé des personnes dans plus de
50 pays sur terre ça se fait à
totalement à distance ça peut se faire à
10000 à 20000 km de l'endroit où se
trouve l'opérateur de renseignement qui
depuis sa plateforme vous choisi comme
cible possible votre téléphone se trouve
impacté vous ne le voyez pas il est dans
votre poche et c'est tout de vous c'est
comme ça que ensuite des vidéos des
photos de vous peuvent être transmises à
vos pierres et demi c'est comme ça qu'on
peut connaître quelle source est venue
vers vous pour vous livrer un secret
c'est pour ça qu ensuite on peut aller
traquer la source et donc c'est les
états qui comme le maroc cible edwy
plenel comme l'azerbaïdjan ac le
téléphone portable de khadija ismaïlova
on trouve également le numéro de
téléphone dans cette liste d'un
journaliste qui s'appelait ces silos
pineda qui deux mois après l'apparition
de son numéro de téléphone cette liste a
été assassiné ce qu'ils sont surveillés
sont ceux qui dérangent les pouvoirs
sont ceux qui parfois ont fui ces
territoires là pour aller très loin
on a des dissidents qui ont fui l'arabie
saoudite par exemple qui se sont
retrouvés ensuite poursuivi par ce
logiciel là et ce logiciel là c'est
vraiment une façon aussi pour ces états
d' exporter la terreur au delà de leurs
frontières et d'aller traquer les
personnes l'un des exemples les plus
sordides et cynique qui soit c'est que
la fiancée de jamal khashoggi le le
célèbre éditorialiste qui a été
assassinée puis démembré à l'intérieur
de l'enceinte dg torités saoudienne de
sur le territoire turc
au moment même où sa fiancée attendait
une nouvelle d'eux
on de jamal khashoggi surveillance et
elles étaient espionnés et on a trouvé
grâce avec l'aller le projet pegasus des
traces de cette infection là où ça vous
dit un peu quels types de cibles et
ciblées par ce logiciel là par ce
gouvernement là et le sens de la fête
[Musique]
ce que cette enquête démontre c'est que
ces dix pays très différents c'est
d'identité ans poursuivis et en cibler
le même type de profil est ce que l'ont
démontré ce que ça des mondes c'est en
fait un grand mensonge
jusqu'ici les états disais si vous
n'avez rien à vous reprocher vous n'avez
rien à cacher vous ne serez pas sur
cette liste vous ne serez pas espionnés
or on voit qu'il suffit d'être
journaliste et d'avoir publié une
histoire qui dérange le pouvoir marocain
il suffit d'être un militant des droits
de l'homme au mexique qui s'est
intéressé à la corruption de tels
gouverneur il suffit d'être 4 déjà
ismaïlova et de d'être l'une des rares
voix en azerbaïdjan qui dénonce une
oligarchie ultra répressive pour se
retrouver ensuite ciblé surveiller à
quai et ce qui est encore plus grave
c'est que les citoyens ne peuvent pas se
défendre ni à leur niveau avec mon
téléphone portable je ne peux rien faire
contre ça l' attaque est invisible
ni même au niveau de ma défense
judiciaire
y'a rien qui puisse être fait
aujourd'hui parce que les preuves sont
difficiles automnale parce que les
gouvernements ne sont pas transparents
parce que le marché n'est pas régulé et
c'est aussi la question que pose le
projet pegasus c'est que c'est un marché
qui est privé la firme qui le vent est
une firme privée et que les états achète
une société privée dans un cadre de
droit qui est franchement pas encore
bâtis